and for the rest of you kids out there a
word of advice
oh
hello
didn't see you there hi I'm Paul Rudd
you might know me as Scott Lang AKA
Ant-Man now Scott has many things former
convict a dad an adventure but he's also
a best-selling author
and now you can purchase my his
very real book look out for the little
guy
that's right this once movie prop is now
an actual real life book you can
purchase wherever books are sold how's
that for meta in this new book I'm
almost certain was not written by me we
pulled back the curtain and uncover The
Man Behind Ant-Man Scott Lang who is he
what's he like
why does he look so much like me it's a
tale as old as time that's so good it
practically reads itself a publication
similar to but not the New York Times
calls it one of the best Avengers
autobiographies of this Multiverse so if
you're like me and you've only ever read
the back covers of books to say you've
read them do yourself a favor and pick
up a copy of look out for the little guy
it'll change your life
[Music]
can I say that
no
it might change your life